[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you know what we have you troll Houston
feet Soho how tall were you and you're
at your highest point I would I was
about six to now I'm about five 11 mm I
thought they were making my pants too
long what happened you just start
shrinking okay I'll just comb this up
higher as I start to shrink another
exactly yeah anywhere I can get it I'll
take it I have to tell you I have to ask
you something first of all I don't often
mention ages here but I think this is
something to be really proud of you just
turned 89 89 what for your line if I had
known as lived this long I would taken
better care of my well you know first of
all you are in better shape than most
people I know in their 50s you're in
incredible shape how did you have this
come to be did you always take care of
yourself well you were when you were
working saying the Dick Van Dyke Show
you're in your 30s 40s were you taking
care of yourself then
well I boys exercise this whole secret
is you got to keep moving keep moving
yeah the publisher asked me to write a
book about being older I said it's very
short keep moving keep moving
did you work out then would you come
with as a stage of life did you work out
through every stage then right right
my motivation changes over the years I
mean my 30s I worked out you know I look
good and my fifties I did it to stay fit
right in my 70s I did it to stay
ambulatory right now I'm doing it to
avoid assistant look at me
but it is very important you anybody
who's getting up there keep moving you
know what's amazing to me is that I've
always thought you've had one that you
have one of the best faces in the
business just such a great comedic face
and so alive and then I'm told that it
at a point your career you were told you
should get work done is that right you
well I would I know I went to England to
do uh to do chitty-chitty-bang-bang yeah
and the first day on the set the guys
making me up and I see the director
motioning to the makeup guy and I
overheard him say what are you gonna do
about the hooter oh that's the hooter
yeah it's the meaning changed over time
oh yeah that's like that back then oh
yeah and I heard him say I'm not a
plastic surgeon right yeah years later I
went to a guy and I said could you take
this bulb off my nose he said you're
established you can't change it now
so I'm now stuck with it I think you
made the right call I think you've made
they're all the right moves obviously
you've had many great successes in your
career but you are forever linked with
Mary Tyler Moore right and a number of
years ago you guys did this photo
together and I have to ask you about it
this is this is not photoshopped you you
and Mary Tyler Moore posed for this
photograph in those outfits in a manner
of speaking yeah we made we did one as a
couple of hobos which I loved right like
clowns mm-hmm and they said put on this
outfit and I said what is this so we're
gonna do like a motorcycle thing so I
put on the outfit
a motorcycle yeah so I thought we were
gonna be on a bike or something and she
what was the lady's name that famous
photographer I don't think that's Annie
Leibovitz great photographers of all
time took this photo get you for this
Annie yeah they said just you know get
out of your knees a minute and knees at
what point you're so naive
at what point dick does it dawn on you
it's not a motorcycle I think oh I guess
I'm the mold yeah I'm gonna change the
oil on the motorcycle I didn't get it
till Mary jumped on my back with that
whip seems like Mary knew or was going
yeah your face just looks like I'm gonna
figure this out at some point we're
taking a long time to bring that
motorcycle around that's gonna haunt you
to the end of my days
you